you gotta talk about this right away
this you got hit pretty hard playing the
Vikings and walk us through what
happened and we've all seen the pain but
I want to make you relive this yeah I
roll that to my right I threw the ball
and I got tackled and kind of slammed on
the ground I looked over at him as I
walked off the field the cameras caught
me saying something him but what they
missed was him finger sucking sign what
yeah the guy who tackled you yeah gave
me the finger and the suckit sign yeah
there's no respect anymore in this
business that's not the football I grew
up watching but I'm good enough 13
screws later and Here I am uh 13 screws
later right let's talk about you as a
gamer people know that you're an amazing
quarterback an incredible athlete you
have another side tell ya that's a big
gamer I love I love video games would
you describe yourself as more jock or
nerd or are you a strange exotic blend
of both I think I'm more nerd nerd yeah
it's not amazing hmm you're a nerd that
could beat up other nerds fantastic that
was always my dream is to be the nerd
who could savagely beat other nerds and
score the winning touchdown to be a nerd
er to beat up other jocks to that's even
better I would be the nerd that would
beat up chops that's a Penta that's what
you are going for you're the nerd that
beats up jocks this is a movie I'm gonna
be there by the way I'm just gonna I'm
not cutting you in for any of ya I don't
ya don't see I'd love to be seeing a
couple you're okay that's biodome three
cut out what say you and I were in a
fight yeah who do you think would win
it's hypothetical right yeah be honest
be completely honest like a fight and
there's no other parameters just me and
you fighting I have a stick
and you're not ready for the fight
you're not I'm not a stick and it's a
big stick big stick yeah and you're much
older than you are now you're gonna
there's a hippo - I'm riding a hitch
you think you win thank you I hope you
meant very quickly and you look tired
excuse me sir I'm looking at you you
look after this man or I will rip off
your head and your throat
you